and numeric and number i didn't share
data they were just two so you could
have a gigabyte of numeric number data
and gigabyte of numeric data and they
wouldn't share it yeah and so you have
these then you have these scientific
libraries written on top
i got really bugged by that yeah i got
really like oh man this is not good
we're not cooperating now we're not
we're sort of redoing each other's work
and we're just this young community
so that's what led me
even though i knew it was risky because
my
you know i had i was on a tanner track
position 2004 i got reviewed they said
hey things are going okay you're doing
well paper's coming out but you're kind
of spending a lot of time on this open
source stuff maybe do a little less of
that and a little more of the paper
writing and grant writing which was
naive but it was definitely the time you
know the thinking it still goes on still
goes on
you're basically creating a thing which
enables science in the 21st century
right um maybe don't emphasize that so
much in your for your tenure right
it illustrates some of the challenges
yeah it does it's and it's people mean
well yeah like but we've gotten broken
in a bunch of ways
certain things programming understanding
the role of software engineering
programming exactly society is a little
bit less exactly no i was in an
electrical engineering position right so
it was even worse
there
yeah it was very they were very focused
and so you know good people and i had a
great time i loved my time i loved my
teaching i loved all the things i did
there the problem was this split was
happening in this community i loved i
saw people and i go oh my gosh this is
going to be
this is not great and so
i happened you know fate
uh i had a class i had signed up for it
it's a i was trying to build an mri
system so i
had a kind of a radio instead of a radio
a digital radio class as a digital mri
class
and i had people sign up two people
signed up then they dropped and so i had
nobody in this class
so
and i didn't have any other courses to
teach i thought oh i've got some time
and i'll just write i'll just write a
replace a merger of the american memory
like i'll basically take the numeric
code base add the features numerator was
adding
and then kind of come up with a single
array library that everybody can use so
that's where numpy came from was my
thinking hey i can do this and who else
is going to because at that point i'd
been around the community long enough
and i'd written enough c code i knew i
knew the structures and i in fact my
first contribution to numeric had been
writing the c api documentation that
went in the first documentation for
numpy for numerix sorry this is paul
dubois david asher conrad hinson and
myself
i got credit because i wrote this
chapter which is all the c api of
numeric all the c stuff so i said ah
probably the one to do it you know
nobody else is going to do this so it's
sort of out of a sense of duty and
passion
knowing that
i don't think my academic advi i don't
think the department here is going to
appreciate this but i it's the right
thing to do
can we just
link on that moment because
the importance of the way you thought
and the action you took
i feel is
is understated and
is rare and i would love to see so much
more of it because what happens as the
tools become more popular
there's a split that happens
and it's a truly heroic and impactful
action to in those early in that early
split to step up
and you it's like great leaders
throughout history like get what is the
brave heart like get on a horse
and rall the troops because i think that
can have make a big difference we have
tensorflow versus pytorch in the machine
learning we have the same problem today
yeah yes i wonder it's actually bigger i
wonder if it's possible
to in the early days to rally the troops
it is possible especially in the early
days the longer it goes the harder right
the more energy and the factions the
harder but in the early days it is
possible and it's extremely helpful and
there's a willingness there yeah but but
but the challenge is there's usually not
a willingness to fund it yeah there's
not a willingness to you know like i was
literally walking into a field saying
i'm going to do this and you know here i
am like you know i have five kids at
home now
pressure builds sometimes my wife hears
these stories and she's like you did
what
i thought we were gonna i thought you
were actually on a path to make sure we
had resources and money but oh wow but
again there's a there's an aspect i'm a
very hopeful person i'm an optimistic
person by nature i love people i learned
that about myself later on uh
part of my uh
my religious beliefs actually lead to
that and it's why i hold them dear
because it's actually how i feel about
that's why it's what leads me to this
these attitudes sort of this hopefulness
and this sense of yeah it may not it may
not work out for me financially or maybe
but that's not the ultimate gain like
that's a thing but it's not that's not
the score card
uh for me and so i just wanted to be
helpful and i knew and partly because
these scipy conferences because the
mailing list conversations i knew there
was a lot of need for this right so i
had this it wasn't like i was alone in
terms of no feedback i had these people
who knew
but it was crazy like people at the time
said yeah we didn't think you'd be able
to do it
you